wait disclaimer there are no stupid
questions
[Music]
what's the difference between a
loop and a while loop what does full
stop development mean is that like so a
piece of paper like do you write code on
stack with paper
what's his API stand for who's this
Jason guy that everybody talks about hey
have you heard of this thing called
react what's the command to exit vim
again oh shoot what did I just do I have
a question for you um its programming
hard I forget how do you
clone something and get how does
recursion work again Oh me me I have a
question
umm what's the difference between Java
and JavaScript like they sound really
similar why are there even that many
programming languages uh do you remember
how to add an SSH key to get what the
heck is this blockchain thing that
everybody's talking about what's the
difference to chain like a software
programmer and let a software developer
and a software engineer hey everyone
how's it going I hope you enjoyed that
little bit right there I wanted to make
this fun little video because I wanted
to show the dumb or stupid questions
that I've asked literally in classes in
school and at work
honestly the point I want to make here
is that there are no stupid questions
and software engineering literally
everyone starts at a place where they
know nothing at all about coding and so
the only way to find out about a lot of
these things is to ask questions
I think it's software engineers because
our job is problem solving it's
incredibly important to ask all of the
questions I seen questions is literally
the best way to learn something and so
asking more questions is always going to
be much better than asking none at all I
also think that not asking enough
questions can end in catastrophic
consequences like if you're going off
with this assumption of a thing and
everyone's going off their own
assumptions of
then you're probably aren't going to
find the best solution possible to fix
or solve the problem that you want to so
no matter what setting you're in or who
you working with I hope that you feel in
power to ask all of the questions that
you have there is kind of an art to how
to ask questions that's going to be the
most useful and productive way to do so
at my job when I have a question I
usually try to like google it or look it
up first and do my own homework on it
and I really only spend like a couple
minutes to a couple of hours depending
on the thing doing this by myself and
then instead of getting stuck for hours
or days on end and wasting my time if I
can't find the answer to that on my own
then I will go to someone and ask my
question they're usually someone that
I'm really comfortable talking to and
someone who is really willing to answer
my questions and I'll either like slack
them be like hey I have this question
can I ask it to make sure that I catch
them at a right time other times I'll
collect a list of questions look big
list and then like I'll set aside 15
minutes for us to just go through those
questions a lot of it is also about just
time management and communication so
those are all skills that will help you
get the answers to your questions
and if you're in a group sending a
question that you might have might be
the Sammis that question that someone
else has like for instance I remember my
very first job we were talking about
this like thing that I didn't really
know the definition of but I was like
I'm too afraid to ask this question
because I'm the newest person I've only
been here for a month and then one of
the senior engineers on that team raised
his hand and he was like hey what is
this and I felt so like heard and seen
in that moment cuz that was the exact
same question that I had and given that
he was also more senior than I was I was
really empowered I was like oh he's a
senior engineer and he doesn't know what
it is either so I guess it's okay that I
don't know conversely if you're in a
place where you can answer a lot of
questions then I think that opening up
the dialogue to make it really easy for
anyone to ask any question is really
inclusive and will really help your team
too and one thing that really helps is
to not shame stupid questions like if
someone asks is questioning and you've
shamed them then that really hurts about
other person's feelings right like for
instance have you ever been in that
situation where like one of your friends
says like a new slang word and everybody
laughs and you're like huh I know what
that slang word means - ha ha ha I feel
really bad when that happens and then I
go home where I'm like what the heck
does this mean on the Internet so but I
mean think about that for like a
technical concept right where it's like
not a funny slang hip thing it's like an
actual concept that you need to
understand to get something done all
right that's it for today so that's all
I have on stupid questions if you have a
question about questions I suppose you
can leave a comment down below and
myself or other people will get to it
don't forget to subscribe and like this
video as always and
next time by
[Music]